in work and outside of work there was a
really big risk that we tried to make
work the sole source of our fulfillment
so I think what we want to do is find
balanced sources of fulfillment yes a
lot of it's going to come from work
because you spend a lot of time from
work but it is why we want to think
about what am I doing outside of work as
well how else am I finding that
fulfillment Helen topper is one of the
co-authors of this excellent book the
squiggly career ditch the latter
discover opportunity design your career
and it's basically an episode that is
all about how to figure out what to do
with your working life I.E your career
and how to navigate what she calls
squiggly careers which is sort of the
windy type of career that most of us are
going to have these days it's about not
being limited by a ladder not thinking
that the only way is up and that the
only destination in terms of success is
becoming more senior once we get rid of
those constraints is actually quite
liberating for people I feel like I
learned so much about my own values and
my own strengths and what I value from a
career and so we start off the
conversation kind of discussing the this
idea of squiggly careers and where
they've come from and then we spend the
rest of the episode discussing five key
skills that you can build today to help
navigate a squiggly career so we start
by talking about values finding and
that's really good we talk about
strengths we talk about confidence
networking in an effective way and
exploring the future possibility a lot
of people are motivated by getting more
money but it's almost like what's the
meaning behind the more money is it
giving you status is it giving you
significance when you work out the
meaning behind the money you can
actually unhook some of your sort of
dependency on the pay hey friends so
before we get into the episode I've got
some very exciting news that I'm finally
able to share with you and that is that
I have written a book now if you've been
following the podcast for a while you'll
probably know from some of my
conversations with authors in particular
that has been quite the journey over the
last three years this has been the
single hardest thing that I've ever done
in my life but after three years it's
finally here and I'm delighted to
announce that my book feel good
productivity is now available for
pre-order it's going to be published
later this year and you can find a link
down in the video description or if you
had over to feel good productivity.com
all one word you can check out the
website and the website is absolutely
sick now the central idea for the book
came from a realization that I had while
I was working as a doctor a few years
ago and trying to juggle everything with
my YouTube channel and my business and I
kind of realized that the secret to
productivity isn't discipline it's in
fact joy and sure hard work and great
and willpower and determination and all
of those things are good in small doses
but for most of us they tend not to be
the sustainable route to consistent
productivity but I realized through a
lot of experimentation and then diving
into a bunch of research that actually
the secret to productivity that feels
enjoyable and meaningful and sustainable
is to find a way to make your work feel
good to find a way to make it feel
energizing and enjoyable and if you do
that you'll be more productive in your
work but you'll also have way more
energy to give to the other things in
your life that matter to you and this
isn't just my own personal experience
but it's an idea that's been validated
by a bunch of studies in the fields of
Psychology and Neuroscience as well and
so the writing process of the book over
the last three years has involved
reading hundreds of research papers
interviewing academics and experts in
the fields of like psychology and
procrastination and motivation and
spending years trying to condense it
into a format and cut out all the fluff
and try to do it in a way that's like
engaging and actionable at the same time
so that's what the book is about it is a
science back guide on how to do more of
what matters to you in a way that feels
enjoyable and meaningful and sustainable
and if you enjoy this podcast then I can
basically guarantee that you will love
the stuff that's in the book there are
nine chapters each chapter has six
different experiments in it that you can
try out in your own life and so there
are 54 different experiments strategies
that you can apply to your life starting
from as soon as you read the book and
the idea is that you apply these and you
see if they work for you and over time
you'll build your own feel-good
productivity system now if you do decide
to pre-order the book then that would be
awesome because firstly it helps me out
and secondly I think the ideas in this
book can be genuinely life-changing and
if you pre-order the book it will be
delivered straight to you on release
date later this year or to your Kindle
or your audible account and I'm
narrating the audiobook by the way power
or to their hardback hardback version of
the book If you prefer to read physical
copies of books and if you do pre-order
then please do be sure to save your
receipts because I'm going to be
announcing a bunch of really exciting
pre-order bonuses exclusively only for
people who pre-order the book and so
final thing before we get into the
episode is just want to say a massive
thank you to you guys by watching the
videos by subscribing on social media by
listening to the podcast you have made
this book possible
um without you guys supporting the
channel and everything that I do there's
no way penguin would have come knocking
a bit like hey do you want to write a
book and so I'm like this has been like
such a rewarding experience and I could
not have got to come to this point
without your support so I just wanted to
say massive thank you from the bottom of
my heart for that so that's it from me
do check out the book If you like at
feelgoodproductivity.com it'll be linked
Down Below in the podcast description
and the show notes as well but now let's
get into the podcast episode itself
hello welcome to the podcast thank you
for having me
um so we're going to be talking about
the squiggly career and the idea of like
how to how to build a career that you
actually love yeah and like the twisty
Tony squiggly path along the way um
before we dive into that I'd just love
to hear from people who might not be
familiar with who you are can you give
us a quick like summary of how we ended
up here oh gosh the quick the quick
squiggly path uh so I used to work for
lots of large organizations uh mainly in
marketing and about 10 years ago so 2013
uh me and a friend that had gone to
University together were reflecting a
little bit on our careers they'd started
quite ladder-like like so leather like
that I did three graduate schemes after
the other because I just loved that like
ready-made incentive of progression that
they come with but then we started to
realize together that our careers have
been going lots of different directions
and we were really enjoying what we were
doing and developing a lot
um but we realized that other people
were still stuck on this ladder like
they hadn't been able to develop in
different directions and we decided we
just wanted to help people uh take what
we had learned what was helping us and
support other people to succeed in
careers that were a bit more individual
um and then the more we did that it
started with evening sessions so while
we were doing our five day a week job we
would go train people in the evening and
that stuff just started to stick and
people started to share it and this
business sort of grew that became a book
and it became a podcast and it became a
big training company and sort of 10
years on from that moment that's what we
do today we have a team
um helping people scale squiggly um all
over the world and uh supporting them
with their skills wow that's a great
pitch
um what what is this quickly career oh
what is this quickly career it is a
career where people can develop in
different directions so you don't have
to be defined by the last job that you
did and you have freedom and flexibility
to develop in a way that's right for you
that can be in the same company or the
same industry sometimes people think
squiggly is about you know making
dramatically different changes to their
career
um things that you've done for example
you've had quite an extreme squiggly
career but you can still squiggle and
stay in a company it's about not being
limited by a ladder not thinking that
the only way is up and that the only
destination in terms of success is
becoming more senior once we get rid of
those constraints is actually quite
liberating for people because I can go
sideways because I don't have to worry
that that's a bad move or I could go
back to something I did before and it's
not a failure for my future and people
just become much more open and start
looking inward what do I actually want
from work rather than outward what does
good look like on the surface and
surface level stuff doesn't often make
people that happy it's the inward stuff
that's better um
what what is a career these days like
how do we understand that word yeah what
is a career I think a career is a
collection of jobs we do throughout our
time at work that's all a career is to
me it's the Journey of the jobs
um what we are trying to say is if you
have a squiggly career that journey of
the jobs
um gives you more choice and it gives
you more freedom whereas if you have a
ladder-like career a journey of jobs
that journey is only going in One
Direction and you are going to have a
limited amount of control about what
that looks like because when the journey
looks like a ladder what a lot of people
do is they have to wait for promotions
because that's that's how you progress
on a ladder whereas when the jelly looks
squiggly you are creating more
possibility for your future rather than
sort of waiting for somebody else to
gift you that promotion um
it is the idea of squiggly confined to
like like for example I'm thinking in
medicine it's fairly ladder-like but
then I know a lot of people who have
quickly squiggly careers within medicine
as well um do you see examples of people
within a more traditionally hierarchical
Fields ending up creating a squiggly
career for themselves yeah absolutely so
gosh we work with lawyers we work with
actually we do quite a lot of work with
um media companies uh who uh are I would
say very
um siled sometimes in the skills like
they kind of go well I'm I'm an editor
therefore I can't go into that function
so we deal with lots of different
organizations and industries that are
traditionally more ladder-like
um and actually because of their
expertise like kind of there's a an
international organization we work with
with ingredients Specialists like they
have phds and all kinds of things that I
don't understand they don't necessarily
want to go and become a teacher you know
they're actually quite happy with their
PHD expertise but the point of
squiggling is it goes beyond a job title
so we're trying to think about your
talent so okay yes you've got a PhD and
yes you're some molecular scientist or
whatever it is but what is your talent
like specifically what do you want to be
known for what gives you the most energy
at work and how can we find ways for you
to stretch that strength so you can
still do the job that you're currently
doing but if you look at your career in
a squiggly way what you're thinking is
well if that's what gives me energy
that's what I want to be known for then
how can I build that beyond the job that
I'm in today how could I build
relationships beyond the ones I have
today because the more we get beyond the
thing we're in today the more
opportunities we create for our future
but in that ladder-like way of thinking
we don't really go beyond where we are
today because we're just just doing the
job and waiting often for someone else
to give us those things so are we
talking like side hustles and stuff or
like what's the how how does one go
about exploring so so let's let's take
strengths for example just for a moment
so if I'm if I'm thinking okay so I I
want to be known by my talents and not
my titles and it's a much kind of broad
way of things people thinking about
their development and so um I don't know
what is one of the talents you want to
be known for
um I don't know I say songwriting okay
songwriting yeah potentially it's not a
talent yet but I would like it to be
okay brilliant so we want to try and
stretch that strength as much as
possible the more people and places you
use that strength in the better the
better it's going to become so we might
start thinking about in your day job
today yeah how can you do more
songwriting maybe you could write the
intro uh the intro music for your
podcast that would be a sort of a very
relevant way of stretching that strength
then we might think a little bit more
broadly
um how could you help some other people
by stretching that strength so could you
volunteer are there I don't know music
Charities organizations that you could
contribute to could you get involved in
schools so this is where you get into
the role of side hustles or volunteering
and you stretch your strengths I I
really like people to stretch their
strengths within their organizations as
far as possible because the more people
within your organization that can see
your strengths the more they will spot
opportunities for you but we want we
want it in and outside of the
organization different people different
places because the way of thinking about
it I think is frequency builds
competency more you use it better you're
going to get an openness leads to
opportunity so the more people that see
it the more people that are going to
spot for you and if we can just keep
that stretch going it starts to build
your brand you become known for that
talent and the good stuff comes to you
love it okay but I have so many more
questions about the strength stuff uh
but but before we go there
um where does this idea of like ladder
career progression come from yeah it's
so it's over 100 years old as a concept
and start in the financial services
sector that's the origins of the career
ladder Financial Services sector mainly
for managers apparently early 1900s
there were I think a big growth in
clerical workers and managers were
trying to create some Conformity over
careers so they could manage and
motivate a rapidly growing Workforce
that's kind of the origins of the ladder
um I'm not sure Conformity and control
are the ingredients for like happy
careers but you know that ladder stuck
around for a very long time but you know
it leads to lots of problems now so that
thing that was created 100 years ago for
one context mainly for managers
um has sort of been extrapolated into
lots of different environments and
situations and the world that we're
working in now is very very different so
we are not working in this predictable
world like most people are going to do
multiple roles in multiple companies and
have multiple careers like it's it's a
very much change and people also
identify with work a lot more it's not
so much going to clock in and clocking
out it's much bigger part of our
identity which means we ask questions
like well purpose I mean purpose it's
just the concept of having work with
purpose is quite a new thing for people
making a difference meaning at work they
are important things for us to consider
but they lead to very different
responses from different people so with
this ladder-like notion what we're doing
is forcing everyone to fall into one
definition of success and meaning you
know become more senior get to the top
and it leads to lots of people actually
competing with each other in in careers
for roles they might not actually want
it leads to quite a lot of comparison so
I might look at you as someone who is
successful and think well I need to be
like you and if I'm not doing what
you're doing then I'm not successful
rather than actually thinking what does
success mean to me and lots of people
lose confidence so this thing that's
been around for such a long time people
think well if my career doesn't look
like that then I'm obviously not doing
it right you get this like the right
career the wrong choice very binary and
it's just not that it's just not that
binary like we all make different moves
we all learn from different things and
we should be using that to inform what
we do next it's not good and bad moves
that that limits people making choices
when they think every move has to sort
of it's almost like they sort of
progression perfectionism which is is
holding people back from experimenting
and exploring and just becoming a bit
more self-aware
where does this idea come from that
we're like every move we make we have to
go upwards in this sort of metaphorical
world I think I mean I think it's been
baked in by the ladder I think it was
introduced and then
we've reinforced companies so we've
created organizational structures upon
this concept I've I've seen and
experienced it and actually I have been
motivated by it because it is it's
already made achievement for you you
know the promises you show up you work
hard and you will go up that ladder and
when that is true I think it's quite
motivating for people that you know I
have a value of achievement so for me to
some extent that becomes quite
motivating but then you get to a point
where that level of promotion isn't
possible anymore because they don't come
around that frequently or the
organizations going through a period of
restructuring and suddenly you're left
going oh well am I not successful now
um is am I doing something wrong and
it's not that you're doing something
wrong and it's not that you're not
successful and it's not that you can't
keep developing it's just that very
limited way of looking at Career Success
and how to develop yourself
starts to hold you back and and that's
the thing we are not anti-ambition I'm
not anti people becoming more senior but
what I'm saying is if you become so
blinkered about your career that the
only way you can progress is by getting
promoted and the only thing that is
success is becoming more senior then at
some point you are going to become
disillusioned about your development and
I I don't want that for people because I
think work is such an important part of
people's life that if we are selling
this story that success is becoming more
senior for everybody we create a
situation where I think a lot of people
are unhappy at work yeah
yeah that's so true
um there's a friend of mine Paul Millard
who wrote a book called The pathless
Path which is kind of like you know he
had a sort of corporate big four
corporate sort of a management
consulting um career and after about 10
years of that decided to completely quit
his job and now just like you know you
know because for internet freelancing
and all this kind of stuff and in the
book he talks a lot about how he had to
deal with all of the societal and
corporate pressures around like oh like
I can no longer go out for drinks with
the co-workers because they're buying
100 cocktails and I can't afford that
anymore and all of the things things
around that but one of the things he
talks about um he calls it The
Accidental meaning hypothesis which is
basically like in the 1950s or
thereabouts because of these career
ladders
um it was the case that you worked hard
at a job you got promoted you got a
company car you lived in the same place
you probably lived in the suburbs you
probably went to church you probably had
a house with a white picket fence you
probably had like three point x kids and
you were probably married and you were
involved in local community and as a
result of the way societies were
structured at least in the West in that
context
you were actually leading a pretty
meaningful and fulfilled life because
you were progressing in your work by
default because of seniority and uh time
and you had meaning outside of your work
by community and structure and like
hanging out with the friends and family
and things whereas increasingly now it's
like the career thing no longer works
because very few jobs are have that
linear progression but also we're all
increasingly living in apartments in big
cities increasingly moving around the
world's becoming smaller and so we have
less of that Community side going on for
us as well which somewhat necessitates
us putting a lot of pressure on our jobs
to fulfill the meaning and purpose
questions of Life yeah and I think that
1950s scenario as well uh I think men's
success in that situation was very
enabled by the women painting the picket
fence at home and so as we no longer
have that kind of narrative I think
suddenly you can't necessarily have that
that kind of system of family life it's
just different and I ultimately think
it's better because now we have more
equal opportunities in the workplace
however it doesn't make it easy that
doesn't make it easy to sort of balance
all those things together
um but yeah I can see I will I will have
a look at his work sounds very
interesting
um what do you think so the the people
that you speak to during like through
the course of your work do you have a
sense of like What proportion of people
are totally happy with their career path
versus like increasingly I find a lot of
my friends saying I don't really know
what I'm doing with my career yeah I
feel like everyone kind of feels that
but everyone feels like they're the only
person who feels that yeah um it's
really interesting I would say the
majority of people
um are thinking about their development
and whether they're doing the right
thing and that doesn't mean they're
going to do something different that
doesn't mean that they're going and I
want to leave my company and I want to
you know retrain to do something else it
just means that they are reflecting on
work and life and does it feel right for
them right now I hire a lot of that and
I think people just need to make sense
they make need to make sense of what's
going on and if you can help them to
make sense okay well well let's look at
what's making you happy at work your
values and let's look at what you want
to be known for
um and let's look at who's helping you
grow so you don't feel like you're doing
this on your own like lots of things
that we talk about then sometimes you
can go through that process and they
become self-aware and they're like
actually this this is the right thing
for me right now but I'm more confident
in what I'm doing and what I'm doing
it's the unknown and the uncertainty
that people really struggle with and so
I think a lot of a lot of what we're
trying to do is to to create Clarity and
give people confidence about the
direction of their development and that
might be actually I'm in a good place or
that might be I want to do some
something different but so many people
don't have the support that was why we
started the business because what we
realized was in lots of organizations
you get to a level of seniority that
unlocks career support so you're like
congratulations on becoming a director
here's your executive coach and then you
go through this Epiphany about about
your your life and your career and you
make decisions and you're like well
everybody's going through that
uncertainty your friends my friends
people everyone's going through those
those thought processes so why are we
only helping Senior People later in
their career to make sense of it why
don't we take the questions and the
tools and the Frameworks and just give
them to everybody like democratize
development don't limit it by level and
then surely everyone can start to
succeed in their careers at whatever
success means for them so yeah those
that that conversation from the friend
and the colleague and the mentor saying
the same thing like I don't really know
what I want to do either that was the
starting point for squiggly it was it
was that we thought well let's just try
and help people because we had those
questions and we found some things that
have helped us so let's just try and
share that with as many people as
possible nice sick okay um I want to
talk about the five skills to navigate
the squiggly career um but before we go
there um what how
what's your sense of how how do people
end up in jobs that they thought they
would enjoy but that they end up
actually not enjoying
self-awareness and a lot of shiny
objects okay so let me I think that the
lack of self-awareness is we we don't
necessarily reflect for very long unless
you're the book on the things that make
you happy the things that motivate and
drive you so we
um make quick choices we sort of bounce
around from one job to the next hoping
that we will find out what makes us
happy once we've got there and I think
if we could spend a little bit more time
reflecting on what makes us happy before
we get there then we can make better
decisions about our development so I
think self-awareness is a is a big thing
we just need to support people with a
little bit of reflection before they
move into new roles
um I think shiny objects is also another
thing and I have definitely succumbed
these so this is where this surface
level stuff so it's um grades like when
you're in uh large organizations it's
the oh I'm a B level and I could get to
the C Level
um and we kind of get very attached to
grades it's shiny objects like literal
ones like cars like I once took a job
because of the car
and I remember sitting in my shiny car
thinking Hmm I'm not sure this job's
really making me happy but I'll just put
the radio on in my car so you know
there's lots of shiny objects I think
salaries just to some extent can be a
shiny object like everyone has a base
level of pay that they need for their
life and then I think there's money
beyond that that can become
discretionary and shiny and impressive
it's sort of these status symbols of um
ladder-like progression and when we
haven't really reflected on what we want
or we don't feel confident about the
choices we're making
defaulting to things that seem shiny on
the surface and can be quite persuasive
as can other people's opinions and
expectations so if I am unsure about
what to do and you're my manager or
you're someone in my family or my
partner and you're very you know clear
about your opinion I might default to
what you think I should do with my
development so you have this situation
where you've got sort of lack of
self-awareness lots of shiny objects and
perhaps other people's opinions and
expectations and I think that is
creating unclear career decision making
where people move into a position and
then ultimately find out that it's not
the right thing for them and we just
have to press pause on that stuff and
help people to get there themselves to
of you know to look inward on those
things and use that to make the
decisions for their development
yeah love it um what are the what are
the ways in which we can do that
reflection reflection thing like someone
watching or listening to this now what
sort of questions would you be asking or
should or could they be asking
themselves to figure out what is the
career that will actually help me become
happier well I think it depends where
you want to start right that's why we
when we talk through the five skills
they are all equally important in
getting to that like where do I want to
go and how do I want to grow and how am
I going to get there they are all
equally important but I would say
they're not all equally important to all
the people all the time so for example
if I'm let's say I'm in a role that I'm
really not enjoying at the moment and I
have been in this position and you're
not really sure why you're like it's a
good job I'm paid a good salary like I
should be happy I don't know what I want
to do I don't know why I'm not happy for
that person I would say work on your
values first there is no point you
moving to another position until you've
reflected on like what motivates and
drives you and you know there's a whole
series of exercises that can help people
there if you've got somebody else who's
saying I just want to do something
different like I do like my job but I'm
like I feel like my career's been a bit
constrained I want to try something out
that person who's quite excited you know
they're not lost they're quite excited
about the potential of their progression
I would say let's go explore some queer
possibilities before you start doing
just loads of random things because
you've got all this energy and
enthusiasm why don't we proactively
explore some possibilities have some
Curious career conversations collect
some data for your development and then
use that to make a decision so for that
person I'd be saying well let's look at
Future let's look at Future
possibilities and and sort of start you
working on that skill so I don't think
there's a one-size-fits-all question for
this I don't think there's like a and
the squiggly career question everyone
should ask themselves I don't think
there is that I think there is where are
you right now and what's the skill
that's going to be most relevant for you
and helping people to spot the skill and
invest in that otherwise it's really
overwhelming like trying to do all this
stuff at once like I don't want to
overwhelm people with Career Development
and I want to give them the specific
stuff that could support them to succeed
and I think that is a very individual
way of managing it nice okay so I wonder
if we start with the values thing yeah
so um you know we've got a question from
Henry from our telegram Community who
says
um let's say you're in a corporate job
and you feel numb from The Daily Grind
you're relatively good at the job but
you're looking to find something that
excites you how do you go about this
discovery process and he's also asking
how do you balance the monetary value of
the corporate job with kind of exploring
other other options that's a numb from
the corporate grind
a motivating statement to start the day
with and so first of all we just need to
take a bit of time to think about okay
what motivates and drives me I think one
of the easiest ways of doing this is to
um we kind of call it the career graph
exercise but you you're going to reflect
on your career so far and some people
have had quite a lot of experience some
people might have a year if you've come
off you know at University you might not
have loads of time that's fine and I
want you to start wherever you think
your career started to where you are
today and just just sort of unravel the
squiggle into a series of highs and lows
and so I'd be talking about my career
started on the boots graduate scheme in
Nottingham and and just describe it and
I would have I would say Okay that was
actually a high for me and you might go
why was it a high and because I was with
lots of keen people and we're doing lots
of new things and I got a lot of variety
because I've changed every six months
Etc et cetera and then I moved into
something else got my shiny car but I
wasn't very happy but why weren't you
very happy and you kind of unravel the
career into a series of highs and lows
and really start to probe the points in
time that were particularly high and
particularly low yeah and the questions
it's sort of like why was it high what
can you learn from the low
um specifically I would I would get
people thinking well who are you working
with and not not someone's name sorry it
was Jane it's more the characteristics
were they entrepreneurial were they
curious like what what are some of the
words that come out or um what were you
working on like a day in your life when
I was on the boots graduate scheme what
was that like describe the detail what
we're doing when we're analyzing these
points in time is we're collecting Clues
because because your values are present
when you're really happy so I'm trying
to collect those Clues like what was
there when I was loving that job what
was present and then what was missing
when you weren't like when I think about
some of my career lows a lot of it is
because I was working in very process
driven organization
um with very sort of siled thinking kind
of people who were quite
um
aggressive in their approach like when I
think about some of the places I've
worked and my values of Freedom growth
and energy and achievement and so what I
can see was missing in those moments was
I didn't have the freedom because it was
so process driven and the energy that I
need wasn't there because people were so
um aggressive in their approach and so
those roles didn't make me happy because
I couldn't get that from my work so for
Henry I would say draw your career graph
like map out those moments and probe the
points in time that stand out the goods
the goods and the bad that will get you
to a set of Clues and you want to spot
the consistencies what three or four
words or themes really really stand out
and that's a starting place for your
values there's more you can do but it's
a pretty good starting place as to what
makes you you
then what we want to do is try and get
those fulfilled as much as possible in
work and outside of work I think there
was a really big risk that we try to
make work the sole source of our
fulfillment and that's where you start
to risk enmeshment which is where I go
well I now know that freedom growth
energy and achievement are what makes me
me so I'm going to try and you know get
as much as I can of that for my work I
want to try and get all of it from my
work and then what happens when me and
my manager aren't getting on or you know
there's a I've hit a road bump for my
business is my achievement value goes
from green to Red straight away and my
entire happiness is affected as a result
so I think what we want to do is find
balance sources of fulfillment yes a lot
of it's going to come from work because
you spend a lot of time from work but it
is why we want to think about what am I
doing outside of work as well how else
am I finding that fulfillment it means
you are less likely to be affected by
the changes at work
um and also for Henry as well talking
about the money so Henry Nano's values
he now knows that maybe find some of
that stuff outside work as well as
inside of work and the money thing
balancing
the the money that you might get from a
role with the meaning that you might
want from your work and I would suggest
that you need to think about sort of the
meaning behind the money A lot of people
are motivated by
getting more money but it's almost like
what's the meaning behind the more money
is it giving you status is it giving you
significance is it giving you security
like why why why do you want more money
is it Freedom like for me a lot of the
time for me yes I want more money but
not not so it's in the bank that's not
what it is it's because I can do new
things when you work out the meaning
behind the money you can actually unhook
some of your sort of dependency on the
pay like I obviously pay is important
because there are certain things we pay
for in our life but it's that
discretionary stuff if you are stuck on
a ladder becoming more senior because
you want to get paid more I think that
can become quite dangerous people's
happiness because it's not always the
pay that's making them happy it's the
meaning behind the money so find out the
meaning behind the money and then just
just see if there's other ways that you
can find that fulfillment or next time
as a pay freeze you're going to feel
really really unhappy and it it's likely
that money means more than just what
you're what's going into your bank
this episode is very kindly brought to
you by huel I've been a pain customer of
huel since my fifth year of medical
school since 2017 actually since before
I started my YouTube channel and I first
started using heal because my life was
pretty hectic I was juggling lots of
different things like medical school and
exams and trying to sort out publication
points for my future like doctor job
applications and alongside I was running
a business I was building an app and I
was trying to maintain some semblance of
a social life and so he actually came in
really handy for that if you haven't
heard of it it's basically a meal in a
shake that contains all of the
ingredients that are essential to thrive
it's got a perfect balance of protein
and carbs and fats and vitamins and
minerals and these days the heel black
edition is my absolute favorite comes in
nine flavors salted caramel is my
personal favorite and the heel black
edition is particularly good because it
is a higher protein version than the
heel original it was the original that I
was using back in 2017 but the Black
Edition came out a few years ago changed
the game because it's 40 grams of
protein for 400 calories I'm trying to
get hinge and so I'm keeping an eye on
like my protein intake and it's so nice
that I can get that high protein hit as
the first thing in the morning heel is
also very affordable it comes comes out
to one pound 68 per meal for a 400
calorie meal which is actually way
cheaper than most of the other options
on the market and certainly way cheaper
than other you know even Standalone
protein shakes like I said I've been a
pain customer of huel since 2017. my
friends literally make fun of me as to
how much fuel I have in the house and
they're like what you have all this
healed I'm like yeah it's actually so
good so if you're interested in signing
up for heal then head over to heel.com
forward slash Deep dive and if you use
that URL a it helps us out because then
they're Keen to sponsor more episodes
but B you get a completely free t-shirt
and a free Shaker with your order so
that is hopefully an incentive to use
fuel.com forward slash Deep dive and
actually I interviewed the founder of
huel Julian Hearn on this very podcast
in the very first season so you can
check out that episode if you like it's
got rave reviews really good episode all
about starting and growing a business so
anyway thank you so much heal for
sponsoring this episode this episode is
very kindly brought to you by
trading212. now people ask me all the
time for advice about investing because
I've made a bunch of videos about it on
the YouTube channel and my advice for
most people is generally invest in Broad
stock market index funds which is
exactly what you can do completely for
free with trading 212. it's a great app
that lets you trade stocks and funds and
ETFs and foreign exchange if you really
want to and one of the great things
about the app is that if you're new to
the world of investing you can actually
invest with fake money you don't have to
put real money in they've got a practice
mode where you invest fake money and
then it actually tracks what the market
is doing in real time so you can see had
I invested 100 pounds into this thing
what would my return have been X weeks
or X months further down the line once
you've got some comfort with that then
it's super easy to deposit money into
your trading tube into account you can
use Apple pay like I do initially or you
can use a direct bank transfer and then
once the money is in your trading 212
account then you can invest it in
basically whatever you want the other
really cool feature about trading 212 is
their pies feature so what you can do is
you can follow people who've created
investing pies for example someone might
have a pie where I don't know 30 of its
apple and 20 is Tesla and 10 is the S P
500 and you can follow people on the app
and see what pies they've created and
you can see the performance of those
pies and then you can just copy and
paste a particular pie into your own
account and so that means like let's say
you've got 100 pounds to invest and
you've put 50 of it into the S P 500 but
you want to be a little bit more
experimental with the other 50 pounds
you can invest it into a pie where
someone else is generally a pro or
someone in their bedroom who just loves
the markets has already done all the
homework for you also very excitingly
there's a new feature that they've added
to the app which is a daily interest on
your uninvested cash these interest
rates may go up or down over time as the
economic environment changes but the
cool thing is that you get paid out
every single day if you're into that
sort of thing and so if you haven't yet
started with investing and you want to
give it a go then you can download the
app on the App Store and if you use the
coupon code Ali Ali it will give you a
totally free share worth up to 100
pounds it's available on iPhone and
Android and you can check it out by
typing in trading 212 into your
respective App Store so thank you so
much trading212 for sponsoring this
episode another good book by Vicki Robin
called your money or your life I don't
know if you've come across it I haven't
oh it's so good uh it's just like that
just completely changed my approach to
money when I read it a few years ago
um her argument in the book I mean it
was it was written a couple of decades
ago but but essentially the argument in
the book is that
fundamentally the only reason we do a
job is to make money and she's like I
know people are going to say fulfillment
and meaning and contribution and like
learning and all that but she's
like but you can get all those things
outside of a job yeah you can get all of
those things by volunteering if you had
100 million in the bank you probably
would you might make slightly different
you know different decisions with how
you spend how you spend your time and
therefore money is the thing so let's
call this pay to spade a job is
fundamentally about money and now when
you recognize that it's like cool how
much of my life my life force My Life
Energy am I trading for that money
um and yeah to your point around like
the freedom the growth all of those
things can actually be found outside of
the day job potentially
and I think I just remember a personal
pivotal point for me was when
um so we were building our business in
parallel with our careers for many years
so it was at Microsoft
um I was a market director of Microsoft
in the UK
um and you know at this point I had two
children and I had my side project and
had the podcast and had the book and all
that was kind of going on and I thought
I I needed to make a decision I'd
managed all this together for quite a
while and I was just becoming I needed
to make a choice it was just becoming a
bit too much I think the trade-off that
I was making in terms of time I was
spending one family and the quality of
the work I wanted to do was I could
start to see the impact of spreading
myself so thin but in order to make the
move to do amazing if my company full
time well I had to let go some identity
things like working for a big company to
let go of that but I also had to halve
my salary and again that that to me was
a really like pivotal decision where I
had to the ladder said become more
senior earn more money because that's
what success is and I'd been on that
ladder for a little while but actually
the squiggly career said work out what's
meaningful and motivate waiting for you
build the support you need around it and
and use that to drive your development
and so
that enabled me to have the confidence
and Clarity to make a move that not
everyone agreed with people like this is
madness Helen so why are you doing this
you've done it like this way for so long
just keep doing it like this but that
has been so much better for my
development for my impact for my
happiness and then I I think because
work does take up such a big part of
your life it has ripples on the people
around you too and I think it has been
better for my family I think my children
now see
me being very happy at work and they see
work in a different way because of that
decision I made about my development and
I'm not saying everyone should make that
decision but what I am saying is that if
you can put work
and money in these slightly different
boxes you know not not the same like
it's all tied together if you just kind
of hold them here for a second or just
look at them slightly more critically it
can help you to make different choices
yeah that's it um this values thing
um a lot of people talk about you know
figure out your values but like what I
liked about the book is that you
actually have a step-by-step process for
how to figure out your values
um so just if we stick on this point a
bit I wonder if we can we just like talk
through it for me like how would we
figure out my values and I'm hoping that
listeners or viewers can then apply this
to their situation okay
um so let's uh let me ask a few
questions sure and then I'll just kind
of collect some instances okay
um in terms of the people that you work
with what's most important to you about
those people if you're going to create
your perfect team what traits and
behaviors would you want to to see in
those people oh
um energizing
uh getting stuff done keen on pushing
the envelope entrepreneurial
um
friendly
yeah okay does that yeah yeah it does it
does I'm going to keep it all in my head
no pen and paper so kind of energizing
uh entrepreneurial effective they're
getting things done so I'll kind of hold
those and what about the type of work
you're doing what's most important if
you're designing your perfect day what
what kind of work that you're actually
spending your time doing and why hmm
if I was designing my perfect date
I really like uh teaching and learning
and so if I could spend some proportion
of my day learning and growing and then
some amount of my day like
applying those insights or something and
then some amount of my day teaching or
sharing those insights through writing
or through making videos or through
talking to people
um more through talking to people and
making videos rather than writing
because writing is kind of kind of
annoying it feels more Contracting
rather than expensive
um that would be a pretty pretty good
day okay expansive is an interesting
word what does expansive mean to you
what does expensive mean to me uh when
I'm giving a talk in public I feel like
more open when I'm sitting at my
computer typing out on a Google doc
I feel more closed that's what I mean by
expensive yeah got it okay
um and then last thing in terms of where
you work if you maybe think in your
career the different places that you've
worked the the team you're creating now
the company that you're creating now
what's important to you about the
culture of those places oh okay
so a friendly
um casual
um I remember when working in the
hospital uh the days that were the most
enjoyable were ones where
there was
this sense of camaraderie with a bit of
casualness so kind of the younger
Consultants rather than the really old
Consultants that we were working with
who could have a bit of a laugh and we'd
go to the doctor's mess together and
we'd sort of chat about patients while
having some chips or something like that
that was really nice and then when I
discovered wework and started working
from there when you know during the
pandemic when I quit the day job that
felt like oh this is
this is my happy place I just love
freaking love going to a weework which
is just like nice and the free coffee
and the people are wearing t-shirts and
chinos and what a vibe that kind of
thing amazing so what I
I am listening for the words that you're
saying and I'm listening to the way that
you say them so so when when people talk
about their values I feel like and when
you're getting really close to it if you
watch people you can see effect a very
physical response so some people go oh I
hated it you know they're like literally
they'll use their body like this they'll
come inwards of like oh I hated it in
that job and you're like oh oh why talk
a bit more about this and I'm just
watching the body when you talk about we
work you get you always quite very
expansively with your body or you're
like oh I loved it there's people
they've got t-shirts and and you're just
getting bigger and you're smilier so
sometimes when you're getting close to
what someone's values are you can
literally see it I can see it in the
energy that comes from someone when they
talk about it because remember this is
what makes you you so when you're in
those environments with those people
you're like more Ali it's more you and
or you hear it in repeated words
so there are the words that people just
say over and over so you mentioned um
friendly about three times when you were
talking about yeah you talked about I
really like you know like friendly
people it's important that people are
friendly you sometimes it's like clues
in exact words sometimes it's like a
theme so
um I've been listening to you described
there's some sort of theme I think
something about connection or community
that when you talk about the doctor's
messes like this community of people but
it's a very
um uh like non-hierarchical equal you
talk about wework you know there's this
community of people everyone's there I'm
bumping in so I don't know it would be
Community or connection but what I'm
trying to spot is these words that you
say frequently the clues as well there's
some words that are similar there's a
cluster and then your your body language
and that that's all data and for me I'm
just like listening and learning and if
I could just get you talking even more I
would get more data I'd collect more
clues and then it is not my job to say
to you and here are your values like
that that's your decision but part of
what we're trying to do and people can
do this on their own or supported by
somebody else is to look at these Clues
and say okay what does feel most like me
I'm just presenting you with what you've
played back to me but I'm doing it in a
way that creates Clarity so you said
words like and you talked a lot about um
entrepreneurialism I thought that
expansive word was really interesting
you know you talked a lot about I like
learning and growing and sharing and I
was like oh is that expanding knowledge
is that your value like you're expanding
your own knowledge you're expanding
other people's knowledge I like to
listen out for like particularly what I
think are sticky words words that other
people don't say because then they're
more meaningful and memorable to you yep
well it's not like I've ticked it off a
list like I don't really want people to
just go through a list and go oh yes
I've got a value of ambition and I've
got a value of this you know you might
have it but let's talk about it for a
bit longer what does that word mean to
you because if I can find the sticky
words it's more likely to stick with you
and then you're more likely to use it
when you're thinking about your career
damn that's really good it's like you've
done this before well I'm just blown
away
um so is there a list of words that
someone could look through and be like
because like there is yes it's in the
book because we have to put it in and
everyone loves a list but um I just want
people to think before they tip you know
I want I want you to really think about
what a brilliant day looks like and what
a bad look day looks like and I want you
to pick apart those moments and reflect
on it and I want you to talk to someone
I want them to listen to you and then
you can go to a list but the list should
reinforce you know so it's I think use
your reflection first and then you can
look at a list and you can go oh yeah
that was the word I meant yes that
that's it that's it or ah I think I've
missed that rather than
taking one minute to scan through a list
of words and going tick tick tick and
move on like values on a tick list they
have formed through a lot of your life
experience and we need to unpick and
reflect upon that in order for us to
really do the work like do the work but
it's worth it if you can work out what
your values are you will be happier at
work you'll make better choices about
your development and you'll build better
relationships with other people it is
worth doing the work so yes there's a
list but I'm just gonna encourage
everyone to like do do the work first
love it um what is a good amount of
values to have in one's mind yeah I I
would say three to four so if you look
in the research of this there's
difference between core values and
satellite values so satellite values are
basically like the long list of things
that are important to you you might have
10 you might you might be okay well I've
got entrepreneurialism and I've got
achievement and I've got community and
I've got knowledge and you have this
long list but we want to get down to
three to four and there's a few ways
that you can you could do that I mean
sometimes you could look at it and be
like it's those
um if I just took some words now that
you've said to me
um these may or may not be your values
because you haven't chosen them but
let's say I take the words uh some of
the words you mentioned so um
entrepreneurism uh Community uh growth
and I want to say friendly you had that
one in there so what I could say to you
is um what's more important to you
entrepreneurialism or community
community what's more important to you
entrepreneurialism or um knowledge
knowledge what's more important to you
entrepreneurialism or friendly friendly
okay then we'd go to the the second one
where I'd talk to you about Community
what's more important to you community
or entrepreneurism Community what's more
important to you community or friendly
oh
[Music]
it's kind of the same maybe yeah yeah
hey they're getting at the similar yeah
hold that thought okay and then what's
more important to you uh
entrepreneurialism uh or uh friendly
oh friendly here okay okay so ideally
I'd have a few more words and I won't be
trying to do all in my head yeah and I
but I'd be able to see there I'm always
looking at a couple of things here I'm
looking out for the noises so you know
when you went oh I love a new because
that means you're going You're really
thinking and exactly what you played
back to me was they're getting at the
same thing brilliant brilliant brilliant
that's a cluster so you said community
and you said friendly but to you they're
very of course they're different words
you look in a dictionary they're
different words but to you the meaning
of those words is getting at something
very very similar yeah and we don't have
to worry about the exact word right now
that's just gonna delay us so we'll just
call it Community slash friendly okay
I'm just gonna just switch to hold that
thought and you just take your list of
words and you you score them through
exactly like I was doing there you take
the first word score them across all
them in the next one we're basically
ranking them all against each other to
work out what Rises to the top the ones
that rise to the top that's the
difference between your core values and
your satellite and we're looking for
three to four the reason it's three to
four is that memorable
um because I can't remember a list of 10
things it's memorable it's meaningful
and it's manageable so I can use three
to four to reflect on and make decisions
a list of ten I
I can't remember them and so therefore
it's not very useful
um and also I'd trade them off anyway I
would always freedom is my Top Value
trade it off for everything and so you
once you have that clarity about your
core values then you that's where your
confidence comes from to use and to make
the decisions to what extent are values
the same as kind of needs because we
we've used the word need quite a lot and
yeah
I think they're very similar I mean I
think actually sometimes I think the
word values can get in there you know it
can feel a bit self-development too yeah
like I think there are some people
really values yeah whereas we call it a
need it's like I have a need for Freedom
yeah yeah exactly and I I never it's
really funny language like we know
language is really important it's what
you know we're talking about confidence
that's why we talk about squiggly where
we know language is very sticky but also
I think sometimes language can just get
in the way
um and you know you can talk about your
values without ever saying the word
values like I might just say to you like
if you're my manager I might just say to
you one of the things that's really
important to me is that I feel like I'm
getting a lot of wins along the way like
that is my definition of achievement but
I haven't mentioned the word values I
haven't even mentioned the word
achievement I've just taken what that
word means to me and shared it with you
in a discussion maybe about my my
development or what I'm doing the
company and so if you want to call it
needs call it needs if you don't want to
call it like you must like one of the
things that motivates me is
um one of the things that I want from my
work is like myself yeah just is getting
in your way of talking about it
that's really good
um
how can you be sure that your values are
not being influenced by external sources
um
why am I'm laughing because my uh the
first time my business partner reflected
on her values she was working in Canary
Wharf and she did them I think she said
it's like on the 23rd story of like a
building in Canary when she was working
in banking and she did all the exercises
uh and she came out with very uh I'm
just gonna call them Canary wolf type
values it was all like achievement and
it was all very like one a one-sided
version of her and a manager called her
on it because I think she took she was
like I've done it here's my work here
are my values I've sat in this room on
my own looking out over London and these
are my values and her manager was like
oh that's surprising I see other things
in you like you light up in other
situations this seems to only be one
aspect of you
um and Sarah's like oh and then she went
away and reflected on it a little bit
more in a different place
um and the words that came out were much
more nuanced and much more reflective of
all all the things that she is and all
the things that motivates her so I think
that is um an example that we can be
influenced by the environment that we're
doing this in the people that we might
be doing it with and I think it's why
with this one repetition is really
important I think you should do these
exercises more than once I still come
back to it I still
um I will still go back to uh the career
graph and I might do it for a year you
know I mentioned doing that career graph
to Henry I might just do it for a year
like 2022 and think what are my highs
and lows in 2022 and now if I reflect on
the really standout points in time the
highs and the lows what was going on in
those moments almost this is a sense
check like are they still are those core
values still the same core values or is
something else creeping in has there
been some significant moment that I
didn't appreciate that's changed my
perspective and I've done that quite a
few times and it doesn't change for me
anyway it hasn't changed but that's I
think this is not just a one-time only
I'll do this exercise and then I'm done
like you your situation will change your
experiences might expand who you are and
so I think we need to come back to this
and the more you come back to it the
more you see the consistencies the more
we know that we've not been swayed by a
place or a person
love it
um
so let's say someone figures out the
core values and they're like ah I am not
feeling these in my work I'm not feeling
a lot of these what happens next yeah
um being there yeah have you been there
um so I think the first thing for people
to do I think is not not to panic about
your progression and just go I'm leaving
straight away and then let's pause a
little bit
um there are sometimes ways that with a
conversation you can increase the amount
your values are filled in a particular
position I've done that I've created
roles in companies that didn't exist
until I did them so um don't I always
think about you know like leaping versus
learning lots of people leap into a new
a new role but we if we spend our career
leaping without doing the learning then
it's not really a great pattern for our
progression so we just want to sit and
kind of think well okay these are my
values how do they play out could they
play out more here could I have some
conversations about my career and what
I'm looking for from work and see
whether that's possible here and I think
once we've explored those different
Avenues you might get to a decision that
I'm not in the right position I'm not in
the right company and then at least
you've got more insight that can form
your progression so I had I had this
experience where I was in an
organization and I was doing pretty well
on the surface that you would have said
Helen's you know doing doing well but
actually below the surface I wasn't
particularly happy and I really pressed
pause on it and I went back to the
skills and I was like what is going on
here and what's going on with my value
strengths and confidence Network
Community I was like what's going on
here
um and what I realized was that I had
several conversations and I realized I
couldn't really do what I wanted to do
with my development there which was you
know it's fine to come to that
conclusion
um that but then when I went to my next
move I made sure that I had some Curious
career conversations with people in
different positions of different
companies so I could understand whether
they were likely to be a good fit for me
so I was getting sort of you know I was
like I remember I went I remember
ultimately I went to work for Virgin and
I remember saying that how much Freedom
do people have in what they work on and
how they work because same as you so
that's so important to me and if someone
said well we do have processes that we
have to follow and work is very I I'd
have a flag in my brain that this
probably wasn't the right place for me
but what I heard was things like um oh
yeah I mean everyone's got AI project
and everyone's doing all this and so I
heard that this was likely to be an
environment that was going to work well
for me and then you know you also want
to make sure that these roles that
you're going for these companies that
you're going to work in that they need
what you want to be known for so you if
you understand what your strengths are
on what you want to be known for you
really want to make sure that they
actually need that because otherwise you
might move into a position that looks
perfect on paper but it's not it's not
going to be perfect for you because it
doesn't need what you want to be known
for and you're not you're not going to
be happy and we're doing a job that
you're going to be energized by you're
not going to make the impact that you
could elsewhere yeah and so just
spending a bit of time taking that
Insight using it to inform the move that
we make means that we make better
decisions but in the meantime because
you still have these needs or whatever
we're going to call you still have
the values within you I would be looking
for ways that they can be filled outside
of work so I would be thinking okay if I
can't get this here and I tried and it's
not happening that is not gonna that's
not gonna go anywhere so are there
um communities that you can be part of
that's been massively helpful for me
communities and contribution outside of
work has been hugely helpful because
um you know if I can be a trustee for a
charity then my values for achievement
and growth are fulfilled in slightly
different ways and if I can you know
contribute to communities and part of
lots of different communities the energy
that I need which means positivity and
productivity to me I get a lot of that
from those communities so our
contribution and communities have worked
well for me when in my career in the
moment my values haven't been as
fulfilled as I might like them to be
we've talked about values yeah what
about strengths what about strengths so
um yeah
you call them super strengths I think
yeah so we call them super strengths and
I think actually since we wrote the
squiggly career because obviously we are
we are talking to people about this
stuff all the time a part of our
business is helping people with squiggly
skills so I think our understanding um
is evolving all the time and I think one
of the things that for me and strengths
that's actually changed the way I think
about them since we wrote the book is
um uh this idea that strengths start
with the things that you're good at oh
okay I think there's like so there's a
little bit a bit of a trap here
so most people will say a strength is
something that you're good at and you
know super strength is something that
you then become great at you invest in
it you become brilliant at become known
for it
um I think the starting point for that
is wrong so the things strengths beings
are things you're good at um
actually strengths the things that give
you energy and the work that you do
um even if you're not great at them yet
so when people think they have to be
good at something or they'd be great at
it for to be a strength they start sort
of dismissing it and they go well I'm
not as good as Alias it so it can't be a
strength because obviously it's your
strength but I'm not as good as you so
it's not it come in my strength and you
get into all this stuff so if we just if
our starting point for strengths is just
strengths of the things that give us
energy it's a kind of easier starting
point it's the weakness thing I just
want to really reflect on for a little
bit so weaknesses are the things you do
that take your energy away when you do
them even if you are good at them and
that's the bit that I want to hold okay
so things you take energy away when you
do them even if you are good at them
because the the issue that I see a lot
is that people have things that they're
good at like we all have like people
we've got a list of abilities right
there's things we've learned to do some
things and natural talents but not all
of those things give us energy at work
and it is a real issue for people's
development when the thing that they are
good at but they find draining to do but
other people see it as a strength and
then they can't get out of a situation
where they have to keep doing it it's
it's a real trap for their career and
what we have to start doing is make sure
the things that give us energy that we
want to be known for that that stuff
stands out and that we are not defined
by the work that we find draining to do
now you can't just stop doing it
overnight so let's say somebody's like
oh my gosh that is a revelation I spend
80 of my time doing spreadsheets and I
hate it like you can't suddenly go I'm
never doing a spreadsheet again delete
um because your manager's probably gonna
get really frustrated with you and
that's not going to help us build the
relationships we need to succeed
um but what we are aiming for is no more
than 20 of our time on that kind of work
um let's just be honest we all have
things that we find raining to do we
definitely don't want to be defined by
it we definitely don't want to spend all
our time doing it
but it is probably still going to be a
bit of your role so 20 no more than that
and because we need to put most of our
effort and energy into making those
strengths stand out that we want to be
known for but also just get good enough
at it like you don't need to be amazing
at it like sometimes it's okay to be
good enough at things so spreadsheets
for example just just get good enough at
it so it doesn't get in your way and
definitely don't spend more than 20 of
your time doing it because if we can
spend more time on the strengths things
give us energy that becomes really
self-fulfilling in a squiggly career we
want to make sure that those things we
want to be known out for stand out
because the more we can do that goes
right back to what we were talking about
about becomes part of your brand gets
bigger and better other people associate
with you they come to you for more of
what you want to be good at and that's
what we want to get to
nice that's a really good way of
thinking about it it's almost a shame
the word of strengths and weaknesses
because it's like
drainers and energizers yeah I mean
language maybe we just maybe I
strengths
can be a bit of a barrier like a mental
barrier they become quite fixed and go
oh I've done a strengths course you're
like okay like and how much are you
using on your job I don't know but I can
tell you what's on my strengths profile
yeah I'm like okay but it's just you
know all those reports and tools and
things they're just an input it's it's
like what we do with the awareness of
Sarah my business partner we're always
talking about it's awareness and action
doesn't matter how many forms you fill
in how many online surveys you take how
many courses you go on if it's just a
load of awareness it's not really doing
anything different for your development
so with strengths I think we've really
we've got to put it into action we've
got to make those strengths Stand Out
we've got to stretch them in different
situations
we're going to take a very quick break
from the podcast to introduce our
sponsor brilliant.org I've been using
brilliant for a few years now and it's a
fantastic online platform for corsairs
in maths and science and computer
science now one of my life philosophies
is that we should all Endeavor to be
lifelong Learners if we want because
it's good for the mind it's good for the
body it's good for our general happiness
and health and Brilliant is a perfect
resource from this because you can
really level up your own thinking in
terms of maths and science and computer
science without having to spend hundreds
of thousands of dollars on extra degrees
or extra courses now the courses are
brilliant are actually great because
they take what could be dry Topics in
math and science and computer science
and they turn them into really
interesting interactive and enjoyable
kind of experiences where you learn a
little bit and then you apply it in
practice and then you learn a bit more
and then you put it into practice and
it's almost like the system that we used
to use in our tutorials back when I was
at University of Cambridge where you
would learn a little thing and then
you'd be paired with a world-class
expert in the thing and then be asking
you questions and you'd be kind of
figuring it out together rather than
being spoon fed information like we're
normally taught in school each lesson on
brilliant is broken up into 15-minute
bite-sized chunks and so wherever you
are in your day you can find a little
bit of time you can go on the app and
you can level up your brain rather than
scrolling social media or whatever the
other default activity might be and it's
pretty cool as well because they're
constantly updating the library of
courses for example they've recently
released a course introduction to
algebra and this is like a visual
representation of algebraic thinking now
I thought I understood algebra because I
did maths in school but actually the way
that brilliant explains it with kind of
the stories and the puzzles and the
interactive exercises you go along has
really given me a new understanding of
algebra that I just didn't have before
and that maybe you would need to do like
a math degree to actually get that grasp
of what algebra actually is and why it's
so important so if any of that stands up
your street and you'd like to level up
your thinking and your knowledge in
maths or science or computer science
then head over to brilliant.org forward
slash deep dive and the first 200 people
to click that link which will be in the
show notes and in the video description
as well will get 20 off the annual
premium subscription so thank you so
much brilliant for sponsoring this
episode and let's get right back to the
podcast the rule in medicine which is
that there's no point doing a blood test
if the results are not going to change
the management plan and it's like you
can do all the blood tests here I can
spend like tens of thousands of pounds
on all the fancy blood tests but it's
not gonna change anything like what's
the point
and I think again and that it could
sound a bit brutal like it could sound a
bit like well you can fill it in but
you've got to do something about it but
it's true I think the thing that makes
it a bit less brutal is is when people
understand the why like why is this
going to be better for me well if if you
are willing to take that awareness about
strength and put it into action you
you'll be more energized by the work
that you're doing and you spend so much
of your time at work do you not want to
be energized by you'll also have a
bigger impact because you're going to do
the work that you find energy that
you're going to get better at and so I
think sometimes we do have to connect
people with the why otherwise it's all
just a bit theoretical like invest in
your strengths and succeed in a career
like it's like but why why does it
matter to you and if we can like work
with the why at an individual level we
can often find the motivation to do
something different to what someone's
probably doing today yeah yeah this is
uh I'm I'm kind of like
annuit myself because this is like the
exact thesis of my book uh which we've
just sent to the copy editor and I'm
like oh I should have mentioned
something about strength oh they love it
when you go back and you add more things
yeah they really enjoy that I've tried
so hard to cut it down it's like it was
120 000 now 65 000 words and I'm like
you're so right I need to add in a bit
because like the whole apartment is what
are the things that energize you and how
can we apply them to our work because
the titleists feel good productivity ah
I love it you know the way we become
more productive is not by trying to
manage our time it's by trying to
regenerate our energy yeah and if close
to everything we do in our work can be
energizing it means you have way more
energy at work as a result you're way
more productive and you feel great and
then you get home and you have way more
energy to do other things hang out with
your family and it's so true I
remember when I started squiggly careers
as a side project so I was at Virgin uh
I just had my first child Henry and I
just started an MBA and I just started a
side project and pretty much everyone
around me was like that is madness like
what what why are you adding this into
that mix you're going to exhaust
yourself and it was a lot I'm not going
to say it wasn't a lot it was a lot but
the thing is I would leave my work my
job at virgin and I would go and run a
squiggly skill session and honestly I
would get there about seven o'clock and
I would probably start a little bit
tired because I'd already done a day at
virgin and goodness knows what time my
little boy got up in the morning and
study was on my mind and so I did start
a little bit tired but that session
would finish by half past eight and I
went home I remember I used to go on the
train I'd get my lunch the dinner from
the station at least at the train and I
was so energized because that strength
that talent I wanted to be known for was
about you know helping people learn
develop and grow in their career
specifically and when I did it I just
died and I just loved it and I gave me
so much energy and I would take that
into my job at virgin the next day and
it would come with me and it would
affect how I led my team and that energy
just continued and so I'm not saying
everyone should do all of that stuff
that I did because it was hard but I
really saw the benefit of using a
strength that gives you energy in more
situations and that actually side
projects some people I think they see
side projects as a competition for the
day job you know like you're doing that
side project because I never saw it that
way I saw a side project as being a
different way that I stretched my
strength that meant that I got better in
both positions I was a much better
manager in virgin because of my side
project it didn't compete with that
career oh nice that's just again put a
puzzle piece in my in my head where
okay so two things one there's there's a
bit of a narrative that side projects
are hustle culturally and like oh you
know it's it's hard enough to get get to
the end of the day of work and now
you're telling everyone that they should
have a side project just yeah just like
chill out and watch Netflix and like
it's okay to have a relaxing bath and
stuff and I've always been like not a
fan of this particular narrative because
for me the side project has always been
incredibly energizing and people would
often ask back when I was working in
medicine they're like oh you know you
were working all day as a doctor that's
pretty minding and then you get home and
you just make these YouTube videos and
then how how do you do all that
I don't see this because like I found
ways to make the day job more energizing
by figuring out what were the things
that energized me and actively
incorporating more of them into the
thing I like realizing I get a lot of
energy from just hanging out with the
nurses and just having a cup of tea and
chatting about whatever so I mean let me
actively make an effort to do that
because it gives me energy and then I
get home and make a YouTube video and
that would give me energy and it's just
like this energy flywheel continues and
then like I was I was never exhausted I
was never burnt out in the job and yet a
lot of my my friends and colleagues who
would work all day get home and then
chill the chill was not actually
regenerating the energy it was scrolling
through social media watching Netflix
yeah in a way that if if you're really
honest like like I get to the end of a
Netflix sesh and I feel drained rather
than energized yeah whereas a side
project I feel energized great let's
keep going I think there's um there's a
thing about active rest that I find
quite interesting that Alex Pang talks
about it in them in his book and you
know that I always think there's like a
scale and on one on one side you've got
kind of restful we're asleep we're in a
great level of sleep and then at the
other side we've got restless where
we're trying to do way too much stuff a
more Tuscan and we're scrolling and it's
sort of like a Restless mind when we're
going through like all these things and
um often you can't sleep at work like
you'd have to be awake to do it so we
can't just rely on sleeping in our day
and we know that Restless thing isn't
really working but Alex Pang always
talks about kind of this active rest
thing in the Middle where you're doing
an activity that consumes your attention
that gives you the energy back and I
found that really really useful because
I'd always thought oh I don't want to
rest because wrestling's doing nothing
and he and he taught me that no it
doesn't mean doing nothing it can mean
doing something that you enjoy that you
find consuming and and it turns off all
the noise of everything else it turns
off whatever was going on at the
hospital or whatever's going on at home
and in doing that thing for an hour and
it can be anything right so people like
doing puzzles like you know your nan
likes doing Scrabble whatever it is like
people like that can be that thing but
it consumes you and it gives you energy
back and I think it's working out what
is that thing that gives you that energy
back but if it aligns with your
strengths even better even better
because then you know you're building
that town at the same time yeah yeah so
when I was when I was reason so the
penultimate chapter of my book is is
about recharging and so I did a load of
research into the papers and stuff
around what is it that makes certain
activities energizing and there was a
really interesting meta-analysis they
did where they sort of did all this and
they came up with like four things it's
like if the thing that you're doing has
these four things chances are it's going
to be energizing or feel recharging and
with a bit of shoehorning I turned it
into the mnemonic uh calm c-a-r-l-m so
C4 I think is competence so if you're
good at the thing yeah it will more
likely to be energizing a for autonomy
yeah if you feel like you have ownership
L for Liberty uh a bit of a shoehorn but
it's like basically a sort of
sufficiently distinct from your day job
or what you normally do yeah which is
why like Ed Sheeran paints rather than
does music as his Hobbies because it's
like music is now his job and stuff and
then M for Mellow again a bit of a
shoehorn but uh things that are not so
like high energy but are like that that
feeling of calm and mellow that we get
from doing things to doing certain
activities those sort of calm activities
tend to be one ones that recharge us and
then the actual words they used in the
study were a bit different but it wasn't
nice mnemonic because it was like let's
do some shoe warning but I think people
don't often prioritize it because they
think it's it's that's not important but
actually the benefit of doing those
things makes all the other things that
you do in your day kind of more more
efficient and effective yeah yeah so how
so I guess we're saying someone can ask
themselves what are the things that I do
in my work that bring me energy and what
are the things that I do in my work the
drain my energy yeah and then it's like
oh crap like
60 of what I do drains my energy what
what happens next so we need to as well
as that oh crap realization we also need
to do that like the oh yes realization
like the okay so those are the things
that give me energy and I mean I would
just like look in your diary you like
look at your days and the meetings that
you've been in the moments in your week
and like just pick out when were the
highest energy moments and what was the
strength I was actually using in that
situation like maybe you were
researching or building relationships or
like whatever you're doing and and I
would write a list of those words and
then from that list I would pick no more
than three no one three I might even
just go with one to begin with to be
honest and the the picking that you're
doing is thinking of these words here
these strengths that give me energy what
do I actually want to be known for I
rarely see people make that choice
rarely see someone go do you know I
actually that is why I want to be known
for if people are talking about me and
I'm not in the room that that is the
thing that I want them to say about me
and I think the risk of people not
making that choice is that they leave
this to chance you know you might say
one thing about me and you know Sarah
might say another my manager that I work
with a virgin might say another and so
then my my strengths are quite
inconsistent you know different people
are saying different things about me in
different places I'm not really building
my brand in a consistent way yeah
whereas if I take control of this if I
go I want to be known for career
development and that is exactly what I
said 10 years ago not known for career
development known for marketing I made a
choice because it was a thing that gave
me the most energy in my day like beyond
the job title that I had regardless of
the company that I worked in the thing
that I loved was like helping people
with their careers yeah to the extent
that I've got some feedback when I was
at Microsoft and someone in my team who
said I'd spent more time trying to
understand the people that worked for me
then I had the company that I worked in
and I was like that is
harsh but true that's so true and
actually that's just Helen you know it's
harsh chew and Helen and and but I
thought it was a very it was a very
clear feedback to me
um and that's because that's the thing
that I love doing so you've got to make
that choice once you've made that choice
you can start to really look at that
strength and see okay well what
situations am I using it in today who
and where could I use that strength with
more and and that becomes a really
intentional thing like I literally
thought okay if I want to be known for
career development what am I going to do
differently in my one-to-ones what I'm
going to do differently my meetings what
departments could I offer that skill to
I could run a lunch and learn
um until it just becomes just part of
who you are because you're just it's
just how you're thinking about the
things that you put yourself forward for
may this is so good I feel I'm just
getting so many dopamine hits and inside
like everything you're saying is just so
sick
wow um what do I want to be known for
like yeah that's
that ties into the whole like personal
brand professional reputation type stuff
which I know gives some people a bit of
an allergic response yeah it's like yeah
um but it's so true it's like and you
know the the thing I always say to
people without really think about it too
hard is like you have a personal brand
whether you like it or not yeah because
a personal brand is just a professional
reputation it's the thing that people
say about you or think about you when
you're not in the room and I guess what
you're saying is like let's think what
do we actually want that to be and
actually work towards it yeah and I
think two two kind of uh things I think
are important here it takes time so I
couldn't come away from here and think
do you know what I want to be known for
being I don't know an expert in like
Neuroscience or something like that
could be like I could make that decision
that's my choice but it doesn't just
happen overnight you know it takes it
takes learning it takes opportunities it
takes experience but I'm just driving
that for my development so I think you
it's it is a choice that you can make
and you can definitely change the
direction of your development because of
it but it does take a little bit of time
and then the other thing that I would
say is you can change your mind you can
definitely change your mind sometimes I
think people think
fine fine just know that you can make a
choice and you can change your mind but
then it will take time to do it it's
also why I say with the five skills pick
the one that feels relevant for you
right now because this does this does
take time reflecting on your values
takes time
um and but you're at work for a long
time so we've got time to do all this
stuff we don't have to rush it we just
have to start like where we are with the
skill that we need most right now yeah
and just like minor course Corrections
along the way yeah
um nice that's great Okay so we've
talked about strengths um super
strengths energizing strength values uh
and we talked about values
um you talk about confidence so what's
the role of confidence in navigating a
squiggly career confidence is the key
company is the key I often think I'm not
supposed to have favorite values I don't
know if I really have but I do think
that that um so I'm not I'm not sure if
those are favorite skills I think values
is at the core of a squiggly career
because if you're going to have a career
as individuals you are you've got to
know what motivates and drives you so I
think values are these are the core and
I think confidence is the key because if
we are going to get people to take
action to do something different to have
a conversation to make a difficult
decision all that stuff they've got to
have the confidence to do it or
otherwise it's all awareness it's all
nice nice in theory and so we've got to
get the awareness and the action and the
confidence is the key for that and they
people have so many beliefs that hold
them back we we call them confidence
Gremlins because you you know you're
really getting to the territory of
psychology here in Liberty and that can
feel quite uncomfortable for people and
quite theoretical language so we often
we talk about these as confidence
Gremlins and we see some very common
confidence Gremlins that hold people
back like not knowing enough for example
a need to be liked and people have some
limiting beliefs about their age like
I'm not old enough or I'm too old like
both of them people have um confidence
Gremlins related to failure like I can't
fail if I if I fail I'm a failure so
there's confidence Gremlin about they
can't possibly fail
um people have confidence Gremlins about
particular abilities as well that really
get in the way their growth like I don't
I'm not good at numbers but any any
numbers any numbers at all just they
just say it often started at school when
they weren't in the top set and then
it's just this little Gremlin has grown
and then they're at work and they go I
can't do numbers or um uh presenting
that's another very common confidence
Gremlin where people are like oh dude I
can't I'm not a good presenter and so
what they do is they stop sharing their
thoughts and their ideas because
presenting is such a big way that we
communicate in lots of companies so I
think with with confidence the the first
thing that's really important very often
is for people to know that they've got a
gremlin and know that everybody else has
two because so often we're like oh well
I might just think I'm I just think I
don't know enough and I'm going to get
found out but like most people have
those kind of thoughts and it doesn't
really matter how senior people are or
what position they're in most people
have some kind of confidence grandma
that gets in the way their growth and I
often find when we're doing like
squiggly skill sessions but it's it's
this moment of like realization I'll be
in a room I was in a room recently with
them a group of lawyers uh and I was
thinking well they're going to be are
they going to be open it's a group of
lawyers talking about confidence and I
was like are they going to be open to
talking about this and we talked about
the confidence Gremlins and I got
everyone to um put their hands up every
time they're identified with one of the
Gremlins and they were putting their
hands up in the room they're obviously
looking at each other in the room and
then we went through all the 10 most
common confidence and I said and what
what does this all make you think well
you've just seen each other put your
hands up what does it make you think and
they um they were like oh we've all got
Gremlins and then they all sort of
laughed and there was like this relief
it was like oh I'm I'm not the only one
they're obviously in very successful
senior positions where credibility was
important so I think admitting that they
had these thoughts was quite a big thing
but once we do it you've you've opened
the door then you've opened the door and
gone okay we have these thoughts and I'm
not alone and it's okay to have them but
now we've got a cage the gremlin so
you've almost got to let the gremlin out
in order to cage it because when the
gremlin's in your head it's in control
of you it's stopping you speaking up in
meetings it's stopping you applying for
positions it's stopping you challenge
someone if you don't agree with what
they think once we have let the gremlin
out we can more consciously cage it
which means that I can speak up in that
meeting now it's not going to be easy
I'm not going to love it because it's a
confidence Gremlin for me but I am now
in control of my Gremlin and I can do
things that I wouldn't have done before
because that the gremlin was driving my
development and now I'm in the driving
scene and the gremlin is still there
because it's very hard to kill it but
you're you are more in control and
that's the journey we're trying to get
people on is what is your Gremlin let's
get it out and then let's cage it for
you and there's a set of activities that
people can do that make that Gremlin
smaller and less significant but I I
always say like
it's probably not going to go away sort
of your Gremlin is a part of you and
it's gonna it's gonna keep popping up
but we're just gonna get better at
putting it back in its cage what are
these um common confidence Gremlins
um oh I have to run them from my head
now uh so things like um a fear of not
knowing enough fear of not being good
enough fear of not being liked a fear of
failure uh age-related confidence
Gremlin the theory of presenting the
fear of senior people I think just one
some people like just really fiercely
people have a whole different identity
when I see the person's in the room one
of the ones that I find funny and I hate
saying this because confidence aren't
that funny but it's just
um it's a fear of uncontrolled bodily
reactions I find it funny because it's a
funny thing but basically
some people have a confidence Gremlin
about how their body reacts when they
are put under pressure
so they might blush for example you know
let them again blush on the neck or they
might perspire or maybe their hands
might shake a little bit in a situation
or maybe they're both stuttered all that
kind of stuff like it's not particularly
something they can control because it's
driven by the adrenaline that's created
by that situation that they're in but
for them the confidence Gremlin is more
what other people will think of them if
they see that happening and so because
they're so worried about what other
people will think if they see their neck
going out of all this stuff they don't
put themselves in a position where
that's that outcome is possible which
means they don't put themselves in a
position where they might be under
pressure which means they play it safe
in their career and so it becomes really
they're like oh I'm never going to
present on a stage because I've lust and
then people think I don't know what I'm
talking about and it's like the thing
with confidence scramblers is often when
you go uh and get some feedback from
other people they see that situation
very differently like a confidence
create a real filter that we look
through that other people don't see in
the same way so they might say you know
they might have gone they might do the
presentation they're blushing and
they're thinking oh that was awful and
then they might go to a colleague and
saying you know what's the one thing you
remember from my time when I was talking
on the stage and the person might say oh
and like you were so clear and
articulate or Oh I thought you looked
like so smiley and like everything
that's played back has nothing to do
with this blushing that for that person
was like a beacon on a stage like there
were this big red Lighthouse but no one
else saw it and so often it's very
useful to get somebody else's
perspective on the situation where your
Gremlin really really stood out to you
because it helps you to realize that
you're it is changing the way that
you're seeing the world of work
um and that other people are not seeing
and experiencing what you are and again
it's just about going my Gremlin is
creating this it's not it's not the
reality it's my experience of it because
my gremlin's in the driving seat and
it's those little moments of insight
that help us realize that oh we can do
something about this this is a choice
this is something I control this is not
what's going on in everyone else's world
let's move on to networks yes so what's
the role of networks oh networks are so
important they they will help you go
further you'll get where you want to go
faster because people can see
opportunities you can't see for yourself
so in a squiggly career we're talking
about people developing in different
directions people are having more Choice
over where they take their career but so
many of those doors will be opened by
other people and so we need the
relationships with people who can see
positions and opportunities we can't see
for ourselves and so we've got to build
that and it isn't just about it isn't
just about new jobs it is about learning
it you know the often you know people
think learning is going on a course but
so much of learning happens through
conversation and in fact it lasts a lot
longer like when you look at like how we
you know learning loss in our brain
discussion with somebody else is
significantly more effective than just
watching a course so our community is a
source of opportunities our community is
a source of learning is a source of
feedback it's an enabler for our growth
um but lots of people I think struggle
with building a network because they
think about it as sort of people knowing
people how many people do I know how
many followers have I got how many
connections have I got on LinkedIn like
that that is like the sign of a good
Network
um and that's not that meaningful that
doesn't mean you've got a good Network
you might be connected to a lot of
people but it doesn't mean you've got a
good Community around your career a good
Community around your career is one that
is active and effective and so we think
about it as people helping people
because if I'm helping you that's active
like here's some help it's an active
thing and you've been helped it is
effective so when we think about people
helping people as the basis for this it
starts to get a lot better and and two
there's two big benefits of it as well
the first is people like helping people
like it's a human traits like you get to
help us high it's like proven that I if
I help you it makes me feel good
um and so when people feel awkward about
building relationships starting with how
you can help and what you've got to give
it it just feels nicer but then if you
look at research from people like Adam
Grant in his work on give and take give
us get more so I actually get more back
by helping other people I get more in
return anyway and this becomes a really
self-fulfilling way of building your
network so it starts people helping
people and then thinking about and what
have I got to give and you you do just
have to trust we kind of think of it as
career Karma but you do just have to
trust that the good stuff comes back
like you can't treat this as a
transaction so I can't think oh I was
writing a book I'll help him with that
because then Ali can help me set
something on YouTube tube it's not it's
not I don't think we want to go into
this in a transactional way you just
think what do I know that can help you
to grow like I literally go around
thinking that and when I say I literally
go around not to everybody that I meet
in every minute of every day I think you
do also need to be intentional about the
relationship you're building for your
career
um there is an element of Randomness
which is like this weak Thai stuff so
the the kind of helping people who you
don't have a big connection with at the
moment because you never know where
that's going to go but there is also a
lot of very intentional building of
relationships with people that you think
well I know that person could open that
door for my development so if I think
about how I can help them then perhaps
in the future that might come back but
I'm not I'm not trading I'm not
transacting with help hmm
nice
uh you talk about the three d's of
networking do you know what yeah there's
a while ago since I've done that in that
book yeah we don't the the we talk about
sort of distance uh donating and
diversity
um so I think the the reason these are
important uh so distance is some of your
relationships are going to be very close
to you so um my business partner she's
super super close to me super important
in my in my kind of uh my network
um she's very close to my context but
sometimes there are people that are
further away from where you are that can
have a different perspective and can
have um you know see things that you
can't see in your world so kind of
distance is quite important when you're
looking at people you don't basically
want your network to be made up of
people you see every day like we want so
kind of some difference there
um donating so we want to make sure that
we are giving because then we will kind
of get lost back um and then we want
lots of difference so you don't want an
echo chamber of people just like you
um and when we're looking at sort of
difference in diversity there are four
roles that we recommend people to build
into their Network so and I think
everyone should have these I don't think
everyone's got them but I think everyone
everyone should have them so the first
role would be a mentor so somebody and
this this gets really over complicated I
just think a mentor is somebody who has
done what you would like to do right
that you could have one meeting like you
could be My Mentor because you've done
something I want to do we've had one
meeting and we might we might not meet
again but you still mentored me it
doesn't have to be this relationship
that endures the rest of yours and my
career so it's just someone who's done
what you want to do and they give you
advice easy
um second one is a peer so a peer is
someone who is going through what you
are going through
um really helpful to accelerate your
development because I can talk to you
about what I'm doing and you're doing it
too and you get it and we can help each
other like Sarah Ellis has been my peer
for 20 years I happen to have to work
with her but my I would not be where I
am if it wasn't for her she's
accelerated my growth massively and the
next one is a sponsor so a sponsor is
someone who can advocate for you so they
have got access and influence over an
area you're interested in so you've got
to just think well what am I interested
in I'm interested in writing a book am I
interested in start a podcast am I
interested in that position and that
team over there like who's got access
and influence that person is it could be
a brilliant sponsor for you
um you can't ask for sponsorship so I
can't just say can you say brilliant
things about me and that team over there
that sponsor needs to see me at my best
so when we talked about strengths we
want that person to see our strengths
like really see us in action they're
much more likely to support us then and
then the fourth role as a coach now this
doesn't have to be a professional coach
they are quite expensive to have a
career coach not definitely not
accessible to everybody the I think it's
better to think of this as someone who's
got a coaching approach which means
they're very good at asking questions
like and and they're very good at just
stopping talking to let you think and
they might follow with another question
but what they are not doing is answering
the question that's for you to do and so
if you know people who've got that
ability they're really really helpful to
have in your career Community because
they'll help you think differently and
so as well as like the 3DS I actually
think those four roles again you know I
said that we are evolving our thinking
all the time we wrote the book well the
book was published in 2020 and since
then we've trained like
almost 200 000 people and then it was
almost like in each one of the
conversations I have I get some feedback
on how effective tools are and they're
they're kind of we're always evolving
them we're always seeing what sticks
we're always seeing what's useful and I
think I'm finding that those four roles
people really focusing on those are what
one of the most useful ways they can
build their Community the principal
people helping people but the Practical
focusing on those four roles
sick
um
one thing people always ask is any tips
for finding a mentor yeah yeah don't ask
for one
yeah I sometimes do get emails being
like will you be my mentor I don't I'm
pretty sure it's not how it works yeah
yeah don't don't ask someone and first
of all I think you need to work out what
it is you want to learn
so um
I might say one of the things that I
want to learn about is uh commercial
skills or investing actually it's one of
the things that I want to learn about
and think amazing if our my business
we're thinking about creating an
investment fund so that other people who
are doing stuff in the career space can
we can help them to grow more than us
just operate in the space and we want to
create an ecosystem of squiggly Crystal
so um but I've not done that before I
don't know how to do it so for me
um who's done what I would like to do a
good Mentor would be somebody who's
maybe built some kind of investment fund
and they've got some experience of doing
that from scratch and all everything
that goes with it so now I know what I
want to learn I can think about who I
might think about who do I know in my
network that's got the knowledge that I
need and maybe maybe I don't know
anybody and so I could go to somebody
else that's in my network and say do you
know anyone who like we don't always
know everyone we might need to know so
it's fine to ask someone but you can be
very specific I'm not saying can it
introduce me to Ali I'm saying one of
the things that I'd really like to learn
about investment funds do you know
anyone who and so it's it's about the
what before we get the person because
otherwise I think people just ask senior
people to be their mentors because it
looks impressive and we've got to be
specific to be genuine and then when
we're making that request for that
person's time I think the way that we
articulate that request is really
important so this is where we get to the
kind of the why I'm coming to you so
let's say you have got investment
experience that I would benefit from I
might say one of the things that I'm
really focused on is amazing this growth
and impact and one of the ways that I
think we can do that is by investing in
other people's businesses I know that
that is something that you have done
before and I think you've got a lot of
knowledge that I can learn from would
you be prepared to spend half an hour
with me just sharing the insights that
you got so that I can use that to inform
the the things I'm planning to do and
well yeah of course if I'd just gone to
you and said will you be my mentor
how much time do you think I actually
have like like there's no it's too it's
too hard we don't want to make it hard
for people to help us remember people
helping people I want to make it as easy
as possible for you to help me now you
and I might have that meeting and that
might be all I need like you might just
be like here's five things that I think
you should look at see you later and I
and you still help me right it's still
been useful or you and I might have that
meeting and there might have been some
kind of connection yeah you're like oh I
feel fine what you're doing is really
interesting I'd actually quite like to
see how it goes and how it grows and I'm
like and you know loads more than I've
got out of here in 30 minutes and
because we've got that sense of
connection that conversation is likely
to continue now this is really really
important for the mentee the mentee
needs to follow up if if the mentee
wants that conversation to continue so
if I'm like I really want to see you
again because there's a lot more that I
could learn from you it's really
important that after that meeting not
same day like give it a few days
actually do something with what that
person has shared follow up with the
mentor so go back to the mentor say
thank you so much for your time as a
result of this conversation these are
the things that I've already done and I
really appreciate it and I would love to
continue the conversation if you went
for another meeting in the future and
because the mentor gets two boosts in
their brain the first boost is when they
helped like when you gave me help you're
like ah made me feel good yeah help us
hide people are helping people second
boost is when you know the impact of
your efforts so when I play it back to
you you're like oh that was a good use
of my time she's done something with
what I gave her and therefore you're
much more likely to give it again so I
think if we can approach mentoring a bit
like that it's I think it's better for
both parties yeah and the word mentors
like never even used yeah yes I help
knowledge and like that's more yeah I
think people under underappreciate
because I feel like a limiting belief a
lot of people have is oh why would that
why would this person this important
person want to talk to me about the
thing
I think I don't realize it like if you
push it in the right way then it's just
it's just nice everyone loves sharing
what they've learned and someone to be
interested in that and for that person
especially to then take action on
applying the thing you're like oh sick
yeah and you might even become friends
and back to you back to confidence
Gremlins maybe they've got a confidence
going about senior people that's getting
in the way of that so you might have to
unpick the confidence Gremlin and say
you know they might hey
um the limiting belief might be a senior
person will never make time for me
um and it might the Limitless belief is
um I've got some I can help the senior
person to see
um I don't know to see this as a
different situation or something you
know like I've got some insight that
they actually could help them because
they can't see this situation from the
position that they're in and so so much
of this stuff is tied together that's
why there's five skills I love it all
right let's go number five future
possibilities yes what would you like to
know
um what uh what do you mean
so what we are trying to do here with
this skill is to help people to be
proactively curious about their career
and if I just go kind of right back to
the ladder for a moment what the ladder
often leads to is people not being
practically curious they're actually
much more reactive about how they manage
their development and the most proactive
thing they probably do is they might
make a plan they might make a plan so
I'll get a piece of paper and I say you
know 2023 I'm CEO of amazing if and 2024
I'm gonna do this and in 2025 I'm gonna
do this and that's I might plan a series
of roles and then I often become quite
blinkered by what I've put in front of
me and and I don't tend to um explore
around it and then the problem is when
those things don't materialize I
suddenly start to get a bit stuck or a
bit frustrated by it so we're trying to
get away from the idea that we can plan
all this stuff and we're trying to get
away from people fixing their future and
so possibilities are more about career
City and instead of fixing things or
trying to be a bit more flexible so
that's the skill here really is to be
practically curious about your career
and you can do that in in lots of
different ways
um what I often suggest is a starting
place here is that people
um go and explore for specific
possibilities like and I don't mean
apply for jobs that's the exact opposite
of what I'm saying I'm saying I want you
to go and talk to people and get closer
to these career possibilities and so for
that I'd recommend people have a look at
um the obvious career possibility so we
we all have a move that probably makes
squiggly sense like when I was at
Microsoft as my manager's job like
that's what people thought I should do
and it seems sensible to do
um now I run my company the sensible
move for me to make is actually just
stay in my job because it's growing my
company's growing and so I will grow
with it that's the sensible move for me
to make and the reason I want people to
explore this one a little bit more is
because a lot of people assume that
because it's obvious it's the right move
for them to make so they take on their
manager's job or they go for that
promotion because they've they're
currently a junior and they should be a
senior and all those kind of things or I
just stay in my role because it's
obvious that it's growing and I should
stay in it
um and actually
maybe that role doesn't actually need
what you want to be known for but the
strengths may be that role doesn't align
with the things that really drive and
motivate you back to your values so
it'll be a good fit for you if it fits
with your values and strengths if it
doesn't then it might look good on paper
but it's not going to be good for you
and so we only know that stuff when we
when we talk to people who are in those
positions maybe we find time to spend
time in those meetings we're observing
it from a slightly different perspective
you know we're kind of looking out for
things so obvious one's a good place to
start
um ambitious possibilities definitely
worth spending a bit of time getting
curious about those so those are the
ones that are interesting but feel a bit
of Reach Out Of Reach right now
sometimes that's because it's more
senior like nothing wrong with want to
be more senior
um sometimes it might be a sideways move
like I might think oh I want to go do
this thing over here feels a bit
ambitious because I've never done that
before
um the issue with this possibility for
lots of people is because it it feels
Out Of Reach they leave it for too long
they're like oh I'm not ready for that
yet or you know people are going to
think that I'm being too ambitious you
know I often hear that confidence
Gremlin uh coming up from people but the
longer you leave it the further it will
always feel away so we want people to go
and have a conversation make a
connection get close to that context
that The Closer you get the sooner
that's good great possibility is going
to become more of a reality the longer
you leave it the further that one's
always going to feel away third one of
pivots so pivot possibilities these are
fun I like these ones
um so in in ladder-like careers we often
look through our progression through the
lens of a job title
that gets really limiting because it
always has to sound senior and similar
um in squiggly careers I want people to
look at their future through the lens of
their talents so who needs what I want
to be known for in my company outside of
my company in this community outside
this community and then you just start
going you kind of get Beyond a job title
you start matching in a very different
way based on talents that's quite I
quite like that one and then the fourth
possibility is the dream one lots of
people discount the dream
so this is like the unconstrained career
choice like we've all got constraints
how much we need to earn and what we
need to live and what we need to know
and all these kind of things some are
very real
um but if you just took them away for a
moment what would you do if you could do
anything
um some people love that one you love
that like you're nodding because maybe
because of all your values uh oh yeah
some people get really scared by it and
they're like I don't know I don't know
um but I get people to sit with it a
little bit and then think well well what
do you need to know like let's not
discount the dream like why why would we
discount the dream like what do you need
to know about it
um and and who could you find that out
from and I always find with the dream
there was a quote that really helped me
to speak what you seek until you see
what you said really help me with the
dream one like speak what you seek do
you see what you said so there's
something that you want to do it is very
unlikely that it's going to happen if it
just exists in your head but if you talk
about it if you say like this is what I
might like to do in the future this is
what I'm interested in is much more
likely that you're going to see what you
said because someone might know someone
or someone might be able to enable it or
someone might just support your ambition
in a different way
um and all you've got to do is have
curious career conversations about
different career possibilities and
sometimes you roll them in and you go
that sounds amazing and sometimes you
rule them out and that's totally fine
and but what happens in the course of
those conversations is you start to get
closer to the possibilities and the
people that are connected to them become
more aware of you and so it starts
enabling and the possibilities become
probabilities which become positions for
you in your future that's that's the
journey we're trying to go on
love it
um at the end of the book you have a
like 100 pieces of career advice we do
um
just to end with like what if this well
what are three of your favorites three
three of your favorite pieces okay I'll
be I'll go mine Sarah's and Simon cynics
okay so we'll go with those so mine
um uh is to run your own race I have
found that to be
a really enabling piece of career advice
for me that has unhooked me from
comparison and given me a lot of
confidence that's really worked for me
uh Sarah's is to uh never live the same
year twice so she's very driven by
variety and
um and that really keeps us like I think
it just keeps her growing really keeps
it growing
um and then Simon cynics that really
stuck with me
um because he was on the podcast and I
asked him for his advice and he said to
um
you don't have to have all the answers
and you don't have to pretend that you
do
and I thought oh it's quite liberating
to hear somebody who is like so
successful sort of admit that they don't
know everything and they don't need the
pressure of having to know everything
and they have to pretend that they know
everything and I was like oh that's
quite nice to just admit that we're all
sort of work in progress so that we
don't need to know everything that that
takes the pressure off so there were
three but there's so many in there and I
think you know you you you read in a
quote what you need right now you know
so I think you know when you go through
quotes some of them they stand out to
you at different moments because of what
what you need so I think it's a chapter
for me that I can go back to and
actually my favorite one has changed
just because of what I need right now
right I think that's a great place to
end this Helen thank you so much thank
you so much all right so that's it for
this week's episode of Deep dive thank
you so much for watching or listening
all the links and resources that we
mentioned in the podcast are going to be
linked down in the video description or
in the show notes depending on where
you're watching or listening to this if
you're listening to this on a podcast
platform then do please leave us a
review on the iTunes Store it really
helps other people discover the podcast
or if you're watching this in full HD or
4k on YouTube then you can leave a
comment down below and ask any questions
or any insights or any thoughts about
the episode that would be awesome and if
you enjoyed this episode you might like
to check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye